Ooh, hello there. I'm an elf and I'm
here for a war party. Yeah, yeah, I got
invited, man. Right here, see? They're
welcoming me, these humans. Who invited
these Pokémon? Man, it's getting diverse
over here. But yes, I've been to plenty
of these. It's always a good time. We
make some mana, so we do some tapping,
and we send in some big mascot to finish
the job. Ooh, I can already see the
mascot looking a little different up
close. I heard this time some lucky ones
even get to ride it. No way they pick
me. I'm just a land lord. But they
picked me. Oh well, let's go then, big
boy. Who are we beating up today? Sneak
and shore Dover. What's that in the sky?
A bunch of pump spells. Wow, they really
got us covered. Well then, let's go get
it.
Hold up.
They're not pumping the frog? Then who
are they Huh?
Huh?
What is YOU DOING, FROGGY? NO.
>> [screaming]
>> THIS IS THE WORST PARTY EVER.
>> [clears throat]
>> HELLO. This is Jin with Next Level
Commander. So, this recent week video
has turned out to be the most popular
video ever on this channel. Not too sure
how to feel about this though, because
it also happens to be the only deck here
I didn't design by myself.
Thanks, people. You've made your message
loud and clear, and so has Ty. But life
moves on. EDH is just a game, and social
media is just background noise. I'm over
it. Just kidding, I'm not. Life is
actually the background noise, and
YouTube clout is everything. This is me
fighting back with my own big brain
budget deck. It's actually one of my
proudest creations, really. I was saving
this for the 1 million sub special, but
here you go, enjoying this exclusive
content decades early because I am not
losing this one. So, please like and
subscribe. This is my one chance. Oh,
and also leave a comment. Let me know if
you think this deck can beat up the week
snail deck. I think I got this. But why
am I hyping this deck up so confidently?
Well, it's because it embodies all of my
deck building perks. Almost everything I
enjoy in a deck can be found here. It's
built entirely around the commander,
Gitrog, the ravenous ride. It is ramp,
card draw, and win condition all in one.
And the deck construction is as
minimalistic as can be. Really, this
entire deck tech can just be summed up
by a haiku.
Yeah, that's it. You can literally turn
off the video now, and you will know how
to build the deck from scratch. No,
really, try it. Take this, make a list,
and see how close it is to mine. But
actually, don't close the video. Play it
in the background or something. Pretty,
please. I need that viewer retention.
But yeah, this is the entire game plan.
Power out Gitrog with elves. Frog plus
protection requires six mana. We should
have that by turn four. And once we
untap with Gitrog, we are saddling with
and pumping the mana dorks. Draw more
pump and protection, drop some lands,
rinse and repeat until your hand looks
something like this, and you realize
your opponents are 15 commander damage
away from lethal. Okay, and now you have
the entire instruction manual as well.
Oh, and the clickbaity thumbnail, got to
address that. I actually never designed
this as a budget deck, but a local
budget tournament made me realize how
perfect Gitrog is for that. I threw away
all the chaff, swapped out cards for
cheaper variants, and it came out to be
$26. And that's after paying 13 cents
per basic land. The deck tech today is
actually for the full budget version,
but the $26 variant retains, I'd say,
about 70% of the power, which is pretty
good for getting a 95% discount. I'll
include both lists in the descriptions.
Feel free to check it out, but let us
begin with our full power Gitrog deck
tech. Starting with mana dorks as an
entry-level position and a bit of a
dead-end job, if you will. So, we can't
be too picky here. Cheap and high power
are the only criteria, really, in that
order. One mana really is premium for
dorks, so we are pretty much playing
them all. Getting one of these in the
opening hand, we are already halfway to
a great start. At two mana, our options
really do open up, but we are still
prioritizing power. Three one is nice.
Conditional four four is good, too. Our
graveyard does fill up pretty fast. At
two power or lower though, you better
bring some extra utility. Having the
ability to scale is nice. It's also good
to potentially tap for more than one
mana. Devoted Druid is actually nutty,
turning giant growths into dark rituals.
Making others bigger is okay. Tapping
for extra mana is also acceptable. Or if
you happen to be Library of Alexandria,
that's okay, too. I've no idea how good
this is, but I do often have seven cards
in hand. At three mana, the cards have
to be ridiculously good, and they are.
Gwena is one of the best mana dorks ever
printed for creature decks. Selvala and
Marwyn scale in different ways, but both
have ridiculously high ceilings. Oh, and
they both also do the turning pump
spells into rituals thing. Spoiler
alert, we have 22 pump spells. And
finally, the honorary mana dorks. We
have Tireless Provisioner and Nissa.
These are some of the greediest cards we
play in such a low-to-the-ground deck,
but when you draw eight and dump five
lands onto the battlefield with one of
these watching, it's all worth it. So
now, thanks to all your hard work, we
have Gitrog down on turn four and
kicking. Who wants to go for a ride? Me.
Me. Me. Me.
Saddle. Hit. And in response to the
trigger, we
>> [music]
>> Giant growth, Titanic growth, mutagenic
growth, supernatural stamina, might of
old Krosa, inner calm, outer strength,
sent to vivify, become immense, take
your own death, invigorate, boon of
Boseiju, Tyvar's limit break.
We do also have some sorcery speed ones,
riskier but really freaking efficient,
like Larger Than Life, Vital Burst,
Rancor, Scale Up. Oh, and Scale Up also
happens to be kind of an alternate
finisher. Yeah, I've won games with it.
And to wrap things up, we have Ronas
Monument, turning all our elves into
pump spells, and Wild Defiance. Drawing
this card usually marks the pivot from
gathering value to finishing the game.
And finally, protection spells.
Indestructible, hexproof, all that good
stuff. My favorite ones are these that
pull double duty, but we also have to
prioritize low mana cost over anything
else. Getting that first hit and the
first big trigger will pretty much
determine the course of our game. So, we
got to make sure it happens.
And that's 60 of the 63 non-land cards.
What's left? Soaring.
Season of Growth. And of course,
Giggling Skitterspine. Yeah, card is
ridiculous. I'm hoping with my videos to
push it up to 1%. Let's get on it. Now,
land base. Lands can be tricky with
decks like this because of how mana
intensive it is. Look at all these pips.
But yeah, some of these colorless lands
we just can't say no to. Like this one,
which is Clinic. This is like borderline
design mistake. It's able to
single-handedly keep a deck like ours,
an Voltron deck, alive in the mid to
late game.
Talent Gates of Valerium, one of the
most versatile lands they've ever
printed. It can be acceleration,
protection, temporary removal. It does
everything. Inkmoth Nexus, if you're
okay with infect, is a ridiculously
efficient alternative win condition. A
lot of my games end with Gitrog killing
one opponent while Inkmoth goes for
another. Reliquary Tower does make sense
in this deck because we do want more
creatures, more pump, and more
protection, and ideally multiples of
each. So, discarding can be tough at
times. Plaza of Heroes with mana open is
excellent deterrent against people
waiting to remove our frog. And yes,
losing our commander can be detrimental,
so Cavern of Souls and Command Beacon
will help a bit with that.
And finally, if we're doing brackets,
this deck actually has no need for game
changers, and it has none up to this
point. But in my experience, it might be
a bit overwhelming and even unfun for
the unprepared bracket two tables. So, I
feel it is best placed in bracket three.
And in that case, Field of the Dead is
pretty good. Ancient Tomb will help us
power out frog even faster. And of
course, Gaea's Cradle. Well again, none
of these are really necessary or core to
our game plan. It's more like win more.
So, yeah, if budget is a concern, these
are the first to go, I'd say. Yeah,
without all these expensive lands, this
list should be around $300 while
maintaining most of its power. The
remainder of our utility land slots are
given to these evasion enablers and a
few MDFCs. One mana dork, one protection
spell, and one pump spell.
And this.
Got to be careful with these cuz they
can't be dropped with Gitrog's ability.
And there you have it, Gitrog monsters.
This is what I'm going to use to face
the snail stack, and I think I'll do
fine as long as my grade four science
teacher didn't lie to me. The deck is
quite explosive. I mean, it's elves. We
can get the frog out by turn four,
sometimes three, and our first big turn
is usually the one after.
As long as we get our first refill, the
deck isn't worried about most forms of
disruption, not even board wipes. I
mean, we do have all the protection, and
unlike many other commander-centric
builds, we're actually pretty safe from
edict effects. This deck is really
simple to build, but it actually is not
the easiest to play. Timing, sequencing,
when to pump the elf, and when to pump
the frog can require some decision
making, but you should get a pretty good
idea after a few play through. The
budget is fairly reasonable if you don't
try to optimize through diminishing
returns, and finally, we sit comfortable
at mid to high bracket three.
That's all for this video. Thank you for
sticking till the end. If you enjoy the
commander-centric play style or a
minimalistic deck building, follow along
for more videos. This will be the focus
of the channel in the foreseeable
future.
I'll see you.